what's the end game I mean there's that
famous David Petraeus line from the Iraq
War where he said tell me how this ends
and and it's the same question now you
go in you go in big on the ground you
let's say you find some way to remove
Hamas from Power you decapitate the
leadership you take control of a large
part of Gaza then what the Palestinian
Authority is too weak to come in and
exert Authority there's been some idle
talk about Arab peacekeeping forces
coming in but there's no Arab state that
wants to do that Israel doesn't want to
reoccupy Gaza again indefinitely so even
if you do a ground Invasion even if you
do decapitate the Hamas leadership then
what who takes charge after that and and
no one really has an answer for that